[Música]
meu nome é andré domingues e eu vim aqui
trazer três questionamentos sérios mas
que são fundamentais para a gente
entender um pouco mais sobre o poder das
experiências multissensoriais nossas
vidas
o primeiro questionamento é porque a
minha mulher decide se casar comigo
agora o mais curioso porque o sexo é tão
bom e por último porque comida de avião
é tão ruim mas acho que responder se
expor cases
eu quero mostrar pra vocês o com um
funeral nós somos dentro das
experiências nas nossas vidas
dependendo da gente ser um homem mulher
foi bonito gordo magro rico pobre e tudo
por causa dos nossos cinco sentidos
deu-lhe um estudo sobre o sentido que
dizia o seguinte os sentidos são o link
das emoções para a memória
isso significa dizer que quanto mais
sentidos são ativados em uma experiência
para o ser humano mais intensa e
inesquecível essa experiência será
simples mas isso tem um preço
o preço disso são decisões inconscientes
que tomamos no nosso dia a dia
o nosso corpo e mente é influenciado sem
a gente quer saber que está acontecendo
só para vocês terem idéia de 85 a 95 por
cento das decisões que tomamos são
tomadas fora do nível consciente do
cérebro é quase como um iceberg 90% da
lei debaixo d'água e do navio a gente
não consegue enxergar isso nos torna
altamente vulneráveis enquanto seres
humanos
e falando em vulnerabilidade veja as
imagens times square nova york
veja a quantidade de informações visuais
as quais as marcas nos submetem da pena
já em nova york quando a gente sai das
nossas casas é praticamente assim dentro
das nossas casas
também é assim e até aqui sentado na
privada na palma das nossas mãos as
empresas nos bombardeiam de todos os
lados a todo momento praticamente 85%
desse bombardeio
são investimentos em marketing que as
empresas fazem para nos persuadido de
que o produto serviço deles a melhor são
focados na visão
tá mas e os outros sentidos
e aí eu pergunto quando a gente deitar a
cabeça no travesseiro quanto de toda
aquela informação principalmente visual
que a gente recebeu durante o dia
inteiro a gente de fato repetem quanto
aquilo a gente se lembra ao dormir
praticamente nada
e aí surge um grande desafio como
impactar pessoas usando os sentidos
isso vale não só para nós como empresas
mas para nós como pessoas e aí eu falei
tudo isso pra começar a responder
os três porque gelado início porque a
minha mulher decide se casar comigo eu
vou contar uma história interessante
sobre a gente era o fim de semana do meu
aniversário
a gente tinha recém completado sete anos
de namoro não éramos casados ainda e eu
iria levar ela para um lugar incrível um
resort à beira mar de porto de galinhas
uma das praias mais bonitas do brasil lá
no litoral de pernambuco o dia
ensolarado uma razão lindo o nosso
quarto ficava de frente para o mar foi
quarta para se organizar para aproveitar
o dia né
eu segurei ela e deu um beijo bem
gostoso nela mas carro foi só um beijo
por enquanto foi só um beijo só para dar
o pontapé inicial no fim de semana
e aí como de praxe e muitas viagens que
a gente faz
eu levei meu violão
e aí eu tinha terminado em organizar
tava esperando por ela
pra variar e aí eu fiquei sentado ali
olhando a paisagem olhando aquele mais
bonito
tocando violão e lembra que a música que
está tocando e aí aquela terminou disse
organizar e eu pedi pra ela pegar
aquelas pai e tinha sob aquelas paletes
de tocar violão que tinha uma caixa de
palhetas dentro do bug do violão e
quando ela chegou lá ela viu que a
caixinha de palhetas na verdade não era
uma caixa e palhetas era caixinha das
alianças e aí ela ficou sem surpresa sem
saber como reagir
achando tudo muito estranho eu posso
garantir que ela estava esperando por
nada aquilo e aí nesse momento eu
comecei a tocar a introdução de uma
música diferente uma música que ela não
conhecia e aí ela percebeu que ao lado
da caixa das alianças têm uma carta ela
segurou a carta e senti um cheiro
gostoso era o cheiro do meu perfume no
papel e no papel não tinha nenhuma
declaração de amor coisa parecida
tinha a letra de uma música só que era a
letra de uma música composta por mim pra
pedir ela em casamento ali naquele
momento e aí eu comecei a cantar ela
começou a chorar e eu que sou chorão
também eu mal conseguia cantar de tanto
chorar era a gente conseguir também
ouviu o som das ondas do mar
era tudo muito reconfortante era o meu
aniversário mas quem ganhou o presente
foi ela
bom eu não sei se eu não sei se vocês
perceberam mas o que eu dei pra ela não
foi um presente algum material foi uma
experiência multissensorial completa e
consequentemente inesquecível
eu tive que apelar para os cinco
sentidos eu que não ia levar um não e
ainda mais um aniversário se lembra
aquelas decisões inconsciente que
tomamos ao longo do nosso dia longo da
nossa vida
minha mulher que eu diga agora já era já
era já era
mas vamos analisar essa experiência que
eu proporcionei para ela sob um ponto de
vista sensorial visão o lugar era
incontestavelmente lindo eu não posso
falar o mesmo do compositor
mas tudo bem dá pro gasto o gasto o
paladar o beijo que deu início a toda
aquela experiência
o fato o cheiro do perfume na carta ea
gente conseguir também sentiu o cheiro
da brisa do mar
a audição o a música autoral cantada voz
violão acústico e também o som das ondas
do mar e por último tatu a textura do
papel nas mãos e claro um anel no dedo
porque graças a deus ela aceitou
agora imagina se a gente analisar todas
as experiências da nossa vida
sob o ponto de vista sensorial eu vou
representar através de um gráfico
imagine um pentágono
cada uma das pontas é um dos cinco
sentidos ea intensidade de cada sentido
a medida de 0 a 10
de dentro para fora para cada uma das
pontas e no final vai formar uma uma
área quanto maior a área mais intensa e
multissensorial é aquela experiência
praticamente todo mundo curte e tomar um
cafezinho como é a experiência de tomar
um café sob o ponto de vista sensorial
visualmente é lindo o líquido a xícara
depender da xícara até o vapor do café
quentinho quando a gente vê traz uma
sensação gostosa auditivamente eu
perceber que algumas pessoas fazem
aquele barulhinho
de sugar o café quente e isso pra muita
gente inconscientemente faz parte da
experiência o tato é pelo ato de
segurarmos a xícara de café
o vapor do café entrando pelas narinas e
o café quentinho tocando nos lábios
o fato e o paladar nem se fala é uma
experiência praticamente intensa então
gráfico fica assim visão audição um
pouco menos tato paladar e olfato
completando a multi sensorial idade da
experiência mas já com uma experiência
de tomar de de ao cinema
o visual e sonoro são incríveis coisa
que dificilmente assistindo um filme do
sofá da nossa casa a gente vai ter a
experiência daquela o tata pelo conforto
dos assentos ea temperatura do ambiente
seja um ar condicionado aquecedor e
olfato eo paladar é pelo cheirinho da
pipoca que a gente sempre sente no
início do filme e o sabor da pipoca que
por si só já é uma experiência
multissensorial então o gráfico fica
assim visão audição intensos e os outros
três sentidos completando a multi
sensorial da experiência interessante é
mais possível masterizar as experiências
imagina tomar aquele cafezinho que a
gente falou
segurando uma xícara mais elegante
acredito mais pesada e ouvindo a música
certa para o momento
e se você for um cinema premium onde tem
aquelas poltronas gigantes e reclináveis
estar confortáveis vocês por exemplo
estão vivenciando a experiência de um
tecto ao vivo
vocês receberam aí cada um de vocês
receberam um saquinho um saquinho verde
que vocês não podem abrir o saco fechado
dizendo para vocês abrirem apenas quando
solicitado
muitos de vocês quando viram que não
podem abrir ficaram tentando se entender
com as mãos o tatu que será que tem ali
dentro
alguns curiosos demais talvez não
resistiram já abriram ao jovem que tem
alimento mas para os que resistiram
eu peço que vocês abrão agora por favor
olha que só um lindo né eu vou pedir
para os que podem é claro degustem o que
tem aí dentro
a gente vai masterizar experiência do
tex em três sentidos de uma vez só
o tatu porque vocês sentiram com as mãos
o que será que tem ali dentro abrir um
saquinho
depois vem o paladar porque vocês vão
degustar aquilo e à medida que vocês
forem mastigando a gente vai sentir uma
explosão de cheiro no ambiente
mas enquanto isso vou continuar aqui tá
será que existe uma experiência perfeita
uma pontuação máxima para todos os
sentidos uma área 100 por cento do
pentágono
existe uma experiência fiquei analisando
e e ver que existe uma experiência quase
que intensamente multissensorial e essa
experiência é o sexo bem feito
isso nos leva o nosso segundo porque sem
dúvida nenhuma é uma experiência que
masterizar todos os sentidos ao máximo
eu não vou entrar no detalhe de como
cada sentido é ativado durante o sexo
se bem que eu até gostaria mas a gente
está num telex
eu vou deixar esse trabalho para a
imaginação de cada um de vocês por favor
há quem diga que o sexo é bom
até quando é mais ou menos desde que não
seja experiência obviamente traumática
né
os sentidos são tão poderosos para a
nossa vida que eles trazem uma
influência gigantesca para o nosso corpo
e influenciando duas coisas fundamentais
e de maneira totalmente inconsciente
o nosso comportamento no ambiente ea
nossa percepção sobre as coisas
a peça opção criada pela nossa mente e
vale muito mais que a realidade e alguns
dos sentidos têm a capacidade de
influenciar outros sentidos ea
combinação de sistemas sensoriais que
vai influenciar nossa
sobre as coisas e isso nos leva ao nosso
último porque porque come de avião é tão
ruim
mesmo sem graça não é que seja ruim a
meio sem graça a gente não dar uma
garrafada no avião e achei aquela comida
saborosa
isso é por conta de três simples razões
e acredite
nenhuma delas é culpa das companhias
aéreas a primeira razão é a umidade
relativa do ar dentro do avião
ela é menor que 20% isso já é mais seco
que muito deserto no mundo pra vocês
terem idéia entre 40 e 70 por cento é a
umidade ideal para o nosso corpo para o
nosso tatu
a segunda razão é a pressão do ar dentro
do avião a cabine pressurizada então lá
dentro a pressão do ar muito mais baixo
do que em terra firme
é como se a gente tivesse no topo de uma
montanha quase 3 mil metros de altitude
ea terceira razão e uma das mais
importantes é o ruído emitido pelas
turbinas do avião que é um ruído
constante e linear e de baixíssima
freqüência isso faz com que muitas vezes
aquele ruído se disfarce no ambiente a
gente não percebe que está ouvindo
mas ela vai distorcer a nossa capacidade
de sentir o sabor doce e salgado em
alimentos e bebidas através de um erro
que liga o canal de tv língua então a
culpa não é das companhias aéreas a
culpa sua
a culpa é nossa são os nossos sítios que
distorce a nossa capacidade de sentir o
sabor pleno em comidas e bebidas
o nosso tato e audição afetando
negativamente o nosso paladar ea
percepção sobre as coisas e aí pegando
esse gancho do ruído de baixa frequência
que distorce o nosso paladar e se por
acaso tiver que estivermos tomando
aquele cafezinho que eu falei antes
ouvindo a música com a missão
predominado de freqüências mais altas
as frequências nas músicas são
determinados pelos instrumentos musicais
e odílio das vozes seja masculino
feminino mais grave é mais agudo então a
depender da música que você esteja
cursando até o cafezinho pode soar mais
saboroso pra você
a música ela pode a música escolhida bem
escolhida a combinação dos níveis de
frequência e os níveis de emissão às
batidas por minuto das músicas além de
outras variáveis bem estudadas como
géneros musicais é poderosíssimo elas
têm a capacidade de nos manter mais
tempo dentro de lojas e restaurantes por
exemplo fazer a gente inconscientemente
caminhar mais devagar pelos corredores
de um shopping ou quem sabe comprar uma
bebida em garrafa de vinho mais cara do
que a gente para atender inicialmente
imagine a música certa até a propriedade
de reduzir nossos níveis de tensão
ansiedade batimentos cardíacos
equilibrar a pressão arterial e por
consequência reduzir o nosso tempo de
permanência a percepção do tempo de
permanência em clínicas médicas e
hospitais por exemplo que são ambiente
que a gente vai não porque a gente quer
mas porque a gente precisa agora imagine
masterizar todas as experiências do ser
humano
harmonizando os estímulos sensoriais
indo no detalhe como cada sentido pode
ser caracterizado para trazer uma
experiência muito mais intensa e
inesquecível para o ser humano
eu espero que isso é o que tem
acontecido aqui nesse tex a gente
conseguiu explorar um pouco mais do
nosso tato o olfato e do paladar como a
gente viu antes
e agora a gente está trabalhando um
pouco mais da nossa audição através de
uma camada com música ambiente necessita
dex mais especificamente uma música
composta e gravada por mim na escócia
quando morei lá então quando você for
pedir sua mulher em casamento
quem sabe presentear alguém especial ou
receber os seus amigos na sua casa para
tomar uma cervejinha os seus clientes no
estabelecimento
independente do segmento pense em como
multissensorial alisar dessas
experiências para a gente conseguir
impactar mais muito mais pessoas
meu nome é andré domingues eu sou
apaixonado por música e pelas
experiências que torna a nossa vida cada
vez mais intensa e multissensorial
fundador da primeira empresa do brasil a
usar ciência aplicada a música ambiente
obrigado
[Música]